here in California one of the biggest
stories through the whole pandemic has
been this startup help curative it was a
tiny company based in Silicon Valley and
they decided they were going to become
it was kind of testing powerhouse and
they are now doing this enormous
percentage of all the coronavirus tests
in California hoping to get up to about
a million tests per week the company is
run by a 25 year old named Fred Turner
so with that we will head down to LA and
talk to Fred for people who who don't
know I mean just tell us a little bit
about your company yes we a pretty new
company just started in January
originally we were a sepsis Diagnostics
company and then in late February we
sort of started to realize that we were
not gonna have enough Diagnostics as a
country to do covert testing so we moved
the entire team from the Bay Area down
to LA we found a lab down here that
paddled the license and everything else
that's needed to do testing and they
were willing to let us come in and build
out a whole covert lab there we've also
built a pretty large team helping people
set up drive throughs so we have all the
software for drive through there all the
training we have a team that will go out
to a city and help them set up drive
through sites and show them how to run
them and we've scaled up to about 25,000
tests per day now maybe you do some
enormous percentage of the tests in
California yeah it's about a quarter of
the test in California okay so I
remember you know as the virus was
picking up steam and the whole United
States was in a testing crisis I just
kept hearing about this startup that was
able to process at that time this much
higher volume of tests then it seemed
like anyone else was doing maybe part of
this is a function of the kind of test
you do right yeah it's what we call an
oral fluid test
so you're swabbing the inside of your
mouth after
often so coughing releases virus from
deep in the lungs that gets caught in
the saliva
there's also already virus in the saliva
and so when you swab your mouth you pick
up virus from these two locations at
once they key to this as it can be self
collected so it doesn't require a health
care worker to Java swab three inches up
someone's nose obviously no one enjoys
yeah so you guys as far as I understand
it I mean you kind of have the person
sit in the car and cough for a little
bit yeah so they drive up to the
drive-thru they are checked in by
someone in the computer system against
their appointment they hand them a kit
through the car window in LA they're now
doing this with like a grabber stick so
they can do it from six feet away they
self collect in the car and then they
drop the kit into a bin which at the end
of the day comes to us okay people have
questioned whether your test is as
accurate as doing the more invasive
tests yes we've done clinical studies
and we found we have a fairly low viral
load maybe you only have it in the nose
maybe you only have it in the throat
getting two samples effectively in one
cuz you're getting the respiratory
sample as well as the saliva produces a
good sensitive C and we've seen that
particularly in picking up early cases
before they become symptomatic and then
from a distribution standpoint I think
what we've seen is that the oral fluid
collection is just the easiest thing for
people to do and in one thing to have a
lot of lab capacity but if we want to be
doing millions of tests per day as a
country you have to have a distribution
method of guessing millions of tests to
people and the only way to do that is
going to be self collected samples the
goal at the end of this month is to get
to 25,000 tests and then to grow
exponentially from there how did you
convince governor Newsom and other
officials to not only take you seriously
but believe that you guys could scale
this thing up to have a meaningful
impact on what was going on
yeah the team behind it is very
experienced in the infectious disease
wolves and then I think the second part
of it is just delivering a lot of other
labs or sort of saying no we can't do
that many tests where as a start-up we
can
move a lot faster than a big company can
okay tell us a little bit about your
background so you're from the UK and and
you went to Oxford and you you dropped
out and I mean you're a young guy you're
25 so started off in the UK during
agricultural genomics it starts up
testing dairy and beef cows to predict
how good they would be for for breeding
did that out in the UK for a few years
then moved it out to California why did
you drop out of school I do it was it
because you wanted to run a startup
become an entrepreneur or it was yeah
I'd already been running the Cathal
genomic startup for about two years at
that point yet just felt like I was
learning an awful lot more during the
startup than in school what's the way
the path forward for you is it just sort
of deal with the coronavirus for yeah
we're kind of a weird company because
our you know our mission is to put
ourselves out of business right where
we're at working seven-day weeks and to
end kovat I mean I I have yet to take a
day off since we started doing this and
we will continue scaling testing as long
as people need more testing we have
drive through sites I think in ten or
more states now across the country and
our current goal is to scale to about a
million tests per week I think the other
focus for us is we have a pretty great
population now of kovat positive
patients that we have been trying to
utilize for clinical trial enrollment so
I can we help with drug development can
we help with vaccine development and and
the pandemic faster what do you see the
next six months looking like here in the
US yeah we need a lot more testing
testing - Brigitte or vaccine is
basically the the strategy every other
path is gonna lead to a large number of
deaths so we either stay completely
locked down and wait for a vaccine but
as a country like that we can't do that
so we have to be able to reopen at least
some things and to enable that we need
large-scale testing we need to be doing
millions of tests per day
you